[Music]
the final night of the republican
convention will feature a powerful plea
for
criminal justice reform from someone who
knows the system
from the inside 65-year-old alice marie
johnson spent more than
20 years in prison after receiving a
life sentence for a
first-time nonviolent drug and money
laundering conviction
two years ago president trump granted
her clemency
after kim kardashian west highlighted
the case
vladimir duties spoke to johnson about
her long
journey what do you want people to know
about
your story how far you've come i want
them to know
that i am a ordinary woman who has been
put
in an extraordinary situation and a
blessed woman
who spent almost 20 22 years
incarcerated with people who i came to
love
who i promised i would never stop
fighting for
alice's story underscores the
disparities and unfairness
that can exist in criminal
sentencing you feel that president trump
saved your life yes he had the ability
to save my life from life in prison yes
he is the one who released me from
that terrible sentence to rejoin my
family
i'm free to hug my family yes
i'm free to live life i'm free to start
over you talked about the family that
you have
and that you left behind in prison we
developed bars
that were just as close really as
bloodballs
these are the women who i cried with we
laughed together we celebrated
we comforted each other we dreamed about
being at home together
my story is the story of thousands of
others
who were caught up in a system and
sentenced way too harshly
do you think that both sides both
republicans and democrats
should find a common ground in
bringing criminal justice reform to this
country as i say
it is not a partisan issue this is
something that should grieve
everyone no party can do this by
themselves
they will have to find common ground and
that common ground is the people who
they represent
and what does that mean to people who
are hopeful who see your story and
are inspired by it i don't let that
concrete and steal
and raise the wire become what i
was going to see as my future a life
forever
so even in the darkest times as long as
you have hope
and you can still dream there's nothing
there is
nothing that can hold you back that was
our vlad duterte reporting of course
it it's this is an amazing woman i mean
to be able to be able to say
you're sorry but i've been blessed after
she even though she spent
nearly 22 years in prison yep i've met
her a couple times number one she's
lovely she's strong and she is a
she's now dedicating her life to helping
others she's a perfect example
of what is wrong with the criminal
justice system and why there need to be
some major changes there
if you doubt that just listen to alice
marie johnson's story it's an amazing
story and
vlad had a very funny moment we shot it
a little differently so if you're like
me going why'd he do it that way i do
not know but
it was a little i was trying to
disclaimer yeah
i was trying to figure that out too but
he had a very funny moment where he said
um when alice first went in you know
social
media was not a big deal so when she
heard that she had gone viral
she didn't know what that meant and she
saw she thought that she had given the
internet a virus
people that she had infected people so
no alice marie johnson you did not do
that
we are so glad that you're out and we're
so glad that you were able to tell your
story and
she's on deck tonight she's speaking at
the room very much looking forward to it
she said kim kardashian west
was an angel in her life who brought her
to the attention to the trump
administration
and she's out and she will be speaking
tonight i can't wait to hear what she's
got to say
all right we'll be right back stay with
us